yeah do you mind uh this morning you
like seems like you spent a lot of time
with your national security team at the
white house are there any updates on
ukraine mr president
no no updates except that uh there's
been no change in the posture of the
russian forces there have
and now there as you know they're along
the entire belarus border
and uh i uh
i made it clear to uh early on to uh
president putin that if he were to move
into
ukraine that there'd be severe
consequences including
significant economic sanctions as well
as
i'd feel obliged to beef up our presence
nato's presence in
on the eastern front paul and romania et
cetera
and uh so uh so
but i see uh
i was
watching one of you on television
pointing out the fact that
i think you've got it right whoever it
was i'm embarrassed i don't remember who
saying that this is all putin i don't
think even his people know for certain
what he's going to do would you ever see
yourself personally sanctioning him if
he did invade ukraine
yes
you would i would see that
what would it take to trigger the
deployment of the 8 500 troops that you
put on high alert and what's your
message to those those forces that are
on high alert those forces in high alert
are they're part of a nato operation
not a sold us operation and i've made it
clear to
president putin that we would be but we
have we have a sacred obligation article
5 obligation to our nato allies and that
if in fact he continued to build up and
or was to move we would be
uh be reinforcing those those troops uh
and i've
spoken with every one of our nato allies
and person are not person virtually
and we're all on the same page we've got
to make it clear that uh
um that there's no reason for anyone any
member of nato to worry whether or not
we would we nato would come to their
defense and mr president
when you'll make a decision about
deploying those troops what will lead to
that what would lead to that is what's
going to happen what putin does or
doesn't do
and uh i may be moving some of those
troops in the nearer term
just because it takes time and uh and
again it's not it's not provocative it's
just exactly what i said
is that is that as long as we have to
reassure
if you notice you don't see a lot of
concern
in terms of
their security of any of our
our nato allies in western europe but in
eastern europe there's reason for
concern
they're along the russian border they're
in the baylor roost border
so everyone from poland on has had a
reason to be concerned about what would
happen and what spillover effects could
occur
we have no intention of putting american
forces or nato forces in ukraine but uh
we i know as i said they're going to be
serious economic consequences if he
moves can you tell me whether you think
sir that the risk of an invasion is
increasing or decreasing or steady just
as as it has been these recent days
you know
i'll be completely honest with you
it's a little bit like reading tea
leaves ordinarily
if we're a different leader the fact
that he continues to
build forces
along
ukraine's border from belarus all the
way around
you'd say well that means that he is
looking like he's going to do something
but then you look at what his past
behavior is and what
everyone is saying and his team as well
as
everyone else as to what is likely to
happen
it all comes down to his his decision
look
let me conclude by saying
there will be enormous consequences
if he were to go in and invade as he
could the entire country
or a lot less than that as
well for russia not only in terms of
economic consequences and political
consequences but will be enormous
consequences worldwide
this would be the largest if he were to
move in with all those forced to be the
largest invasion since world war ii it
would change the world thank you guys
thanks guys
thank you guys let's go thank you guys
you guys come on let's go thank you
there's not going to be any
american forces moving into ukraine